the 10th Commissioner in the history of
Major League Baseball Rob man for good
to see a commissioner good to see you
too how much would you speak to Bud
Selig your predecessor Oh at least once
a week really yeah yeah it's interesting
when I worked for Bud he would always
call me and it would be multiple times a
day since I became commissioner he
always waits for me to call him huh but
um I you know I try to do it at least
once a week and you know we always he
likes to be caught up on things but he's
been very gracious about you know
letting me initiate the conversation I
mean what do you guys talk about if you
don't mind me being a father well you
know sometimes we talk about substance
you know if there's an issue that I'm
dealing with you know he's a great
source of advice 23 years he saw most of
them in some shape or form and sometimes
it's just catching up you know he likes
to know what's going on in the game it
was kind of his lifeblood for 23 years
and you know just kind of catch up who's
doing a lot what is the issue that you
are dealing with baseball's have begun
another started I mean you're about
we're about a weekend you know this is
actually the best time of year because
all of the offseason conversation about
the game and the economics and all of
those issues go away because we're
playing again and it's a great time of
year for us really focused on the field
right now right so there's really not
much in weather in box in that regard
well you know it just takes my inbox is
always full okay but it takes the public
the media focus off the business side of
the game and and gets it where it really
belongs on the field on the field and
baseball has begun so far just a couple
questions about the fact that we have
some good players who have not been
signed yet mm-hmm and it is surprising
to many that's somebody of Dallas
Keuchel ability or Craig Kimbrel ability
is not signed does it alarm you at all
look I I have confidence that the market
will ultimately clear that they will
find deals
but there is no question that the timing
of the market has changed you got smart
people on both sides of negotiations
agents and clubs they use timing as
leverage in negotiations on both sides
and I do think it's unfortunate that the
back-and-forth has produced a couple
really good players that are out there
unsigned it so is there any push at all
cuz you see you know so much being
discussed in the NBA about July 1st
that's the day yeah and the NFL when
their new league year opens up it so
much activity happens on one day and
both leagues can use that as a spotlight
obviously your league does not have a
salary cap and obviously the the salary
cap and both of those sports Spurs
actions right away is there short of
obviously a cap which would be a whole
different story a movement afoot
potentially within your office or your
mindset to try and create a back-end of
free agency to push it all in a certain
spot well here's the problem with
deadlines you have to deadlines as you
correctly point out the the calendar in
both the NBA and the NFL is driven by
the cap system right we do not have a
similar issue so creating a deadline
without ramifications associated with it
it's not much of a deadline we have
talked about we'd love to have you know
the winter meetings be the place where
it all gets done and we're finished with
it but as long as we have
what is the freest free agency system in
professional sports something the MLB PA
is bargained hard for over the years you
know the timing is gonna move with that
market yeah cuz I guess you know Harper
didn't sign until right you know
preseason games exhibition games are
being played right it just could create
some confusion maybe in the mud well you
know it's interesting there was a recap
done of the Harper negotiations in
advance of him playing in Washington
this week and you know his agent told
them early on and it's in the article
you know it's probably gonna be March 1
before you sign I mean that's 10-day I
mean that's an interesting
certian I think supports what I'm saying
about both agents and clubs using the
timing the calendar as a source of
leverage in the negotiations I think the
other thing that the article made really
clear is that you know the timing of
when you respond right Washington made a
very early kind of pre-emptive offer to
Harper and at least if the articles
accurate took Harper side a long time to
get back to him and so if it just put a
button on it if you had your druthers
the the winter meetings where everyone
was out in Vegas is a week long extract
mean I was watching on MLB Network and
just seeing all the general managers
pass by and all of all the bold-faced
names from the sport passed by if you
had your druthers it would be all done
there and you'd be wrapped up and yeah
marketing like crazy coming off of that
I think there's a positive and a
negative right I mean I think that
positive of you know a flurry of
activity when you own a week in December
when it's your offseason that's a really
great thing the second thing it does is
it puts it behind you all the stories
about who's signing not something
they're done and you can move on getting
ready for the season and looking forward
to who's gonna be good how the clubs are
gonna play Rob Manfred here on the Rich
Eisen show the Commissioner of baseball
the question of the schedule with the
Mets Noah syndergaard not happy about it
did you hear about it from the Mets
about playing a night game and then
having a home opener early in the
afternoon and one of the players having
to take a drug test to keep the team
held up for an hour yeah look I mean
obviously we like to be sensitive to
travel concerns our players play a
really tough schedule right 162 times
and now 187 days but the fact that a
matter is one of the keys to a really
strong drug program which is what we
have is a lack of predictability if
player know if players know they're not
going to be tested went on a game day
when they have to travel afterwards
that's a weakness in the programs
while I don't love the inconvenience I'm
really sympathetic to what some of the
Mets player said I think the larger
issue is that we have a drug program
that is completely unpredictable in
terms of when you're gonna be tested and
that's a good thing okay my Red Sox
friend Chris Brockman over there's
probably this is borne out of the record
that the Red Sox currently have right
what's their record right now Chris
what's their record right now 2 & 6 okay
that starting the season on the road for
a World Series champion is something
that obviously you can't prevent right
because the schedules done before the
season's over right did I get that right
Chris yes okay so on behalf of Red Sox
fans what what about the idea about
creating a schedule after the season's
over well we have an obligation under
the collective bargaining agreement to
give a schedule to the Players
Association in July right to give them
an opportunity to comment on it and you
know get it in place secondly the clubs
like the sell against it right they
don't they don't want to wait until you
know who the World Series champ is and
you know it's interesting everybody
looks at our schedule and they say oh
you know you should do this you should
do that well you know another
consideration right is Boston is a
cold-weather City they started on the
road where it was warmer and they will
open at home where hopefully they've had
another week and a half for it to heat
up so you know there's just a lot of
considerations that go into who starts
where so its climate change Chris okay I
understand part of my point is that
other sports the NFL and the NBA in
particular have done a great job making
the opening night of the season with
their respective champions a big event
and I think baseball could take this
that look at them and use it as an
opportunity to do the same yeah I think
that I think from a practical
perspective to start building a schedule
once you know who wins the World Series
just don't have enough time to do it you
know you remember it's 20 430 games
right as opposed to you know
much more limited football right yeah
yeah I mean it's just a more complicated
process and from a timing perspective
probably not workable Rob Manfred here
on the Rich Eisen show yeah Alex Bregman
in our show studio and he was awesome
yes awesome bye and if they think that I
really enjoyed about him and meeting him
is he's like you know young players we
want to sell this game we want to get
out there have you know a view sense
that from the younger players that
they're yeah they're ready to roll we
have a younger group of players right
they're really appealing from a talent
level I mean let's start there that
always helps right I mean they're just
really great players right much more
active on social media you saw a whole
group of them I don't know if you've
seen the second edition to let let the
kids play was fun really a lot of fun
and I think those players are important
to the game to the future of our game to
the marketing of the game I just week I
love that kid yeah he's really really
clever right games week it's a one way
to debts it's a good way to put it yeah
no Yelich as well I mean and he's raking
starting the season yeah also yeah look
I think that I think that to the extent
that younger players find time again
within this schedule we've talked about
the schedule a lot of your already but
right you know when you play every day
it's harder you know you just don't have
that much time and to the extent that we
have younger guys who are finding a way
to get themselves out there engage on
social media market the game market
themselves build their brand you know
their individual brand within this you
know really grueling schedule that we
have that's a huge plus for us do you
like backflips when you see look I like
the idea of players being able to show
their emotion you know I think that in
it gives the fan some insight into who
the player is and you know however they
demonstrate that emotion and commitment
to the game I think it's a good thing
the other thing you know I am a believer
that the sort of unwritten rules of the
game
are the players they belong to the
players right they made them up they
enforced them you know and you know the
fact that a matter is this generation of
players is different and there's nothing
wrong with them
changing the unwritten rules in a way
that I actually happen to believes good
for the game yeah I mean Harper's bat
flip in particular was just that what a
dramatic night that was where the fans
were just really giving him the business
the Nationals Twitter account was given
him the business and then the Phillies
Twitter account gave it right back when
he bat slipped and hit the heck out of
baseball you know it's interesting he
you have to give Bryce credit right he
does seem to have the ability to come up
big in a big moment I mean you saw it in
the home run derby last year you know it
was a great moment made our broadcast
fabulous great for the fans in
Washington and you know with all the
swirl that you're referring to with him
being back in Washington to do it again
you know you just hats off to him we
were saying it looked like the homerun
Derby
I mean yeah the where he yeah where he
placed the baseball right like it was
one of those pink bonus balls you know
everyone in the two-handed flip it was
it was something else what what is the
relationship right now between you and
your the front office and the Players
Association because it does seem that
that there's rhetoric that's beginning
to ratchet yeah but um look we've tried
to be careful about the rhetoric on our
side we really have and but there's no
question that Tony is dealing with some
dissatisfaction among his players about
how the current agreement has operated
in some ways that's puzzling to us you
know you think about this offseason we
spent four billion dollars on guaranteed
dollars on free agent contracts and
extensions that's an all-time record we
set individual records in terms of
guaranteed dollars in contracts like the
Harper contract the trout contract yet
we have this that this discontent my
thought with respect to that is that
rhetoric publicly is not done
address the concerns we have told Tony
even though were a couple of years away
from expiration that we're prepared to
get in a room and talk to him about
whatever it is right it's causing this
dissatisfaction that hadn't happened yet
we've made the offer we made it a year
ago during spring training we made a
written agreement that kind of committed
to starting those talks after opening
day this year and you know we're waiting
to hear from Tony so because from just
hearing from the players again I guess
coming back full circle a little bit Rob
Manfred Commissioner baseball here is
that some players who don't have gigs
right now when some players
are waiting to hear if they're going to
have a gig until the very end and then
some older players are are getting
sabermetrics out of the game right and
that these are all problems that the
front office's in Major League
Baseball's management needs to deal with
well you know I don't disagree with the
idea that you know maybe those are
problems I think that we have offered to
get in a room and deal with them with
the Players Association that's the only
way that meant legally it's the only way
we can deal with those problems and the
way I think about it is this you know
the the union has always bargained for a
free market the free market speaks right
it speaks that certain stars are getting
really big dollar contracts and other
players have struggled more in that free
market if the union wants that market to
operate in a different way they have to
you know they got to come forward tell
us this is the outcome we're looking to
achieve and here's how we think we might
be able to do it and then that
bargaining process is available to
address those problems we're good with
the agreement we made in 2016 we really
are I mean you know we made a deal we're
prepared to live with the deal till 2021
and which of the playing rule proposals
that are being thrown out there do you
want to see past the most look I think
that the one thing that was probably my
highest priority
kind of contrary to the publicity
surrounding it was the rule or the
agreement we reached on roster sizes I
think September has been a problem for
us for a long time I think it slows the
game down when you have 40 arguably 40
players right elbow a lot of pitching
changes but it more important than just
slowing the game down it doesn't seem
right to me that we should play the most
important games of the year in September
with a different set of rules than we
play all year long so I think that was a
huge change I'm glad that we were able
to make that agreement with the Union we
tried to make it in 2016 and just didn't
quite get there so I think that that
that's an important change I think that
after that I would focus without getting
into any particular rule I think it's
important that we try to look at rules
that will increase the action in the
game yes it forget about time I'm not so
worried about time you're saying that
yeah I mean look that that sounds I'd
like to be faster but I think that it's
a dual problem I mean you can be long if
you have lots of action if you don't
have much action you got to be tight
around time and you should be looking to
induce some action in the game yes yes
it's quality of play not pace of play by
the way I don't believe that we're
looking to change the game the way and I
really believe this if you look at the
numbers and I look at them every day the
game is changing organically right we
are getting less action we're getting
more strikeouts we're getting more home
run right right I mean the outcomes less
balls in play more time between balls
and play all those things are changing
and the question is how are we going to
manage that that change I'm not looking
to change it for the sake of changing it
I'm looking to manage the organic
changes going on
so we preserve the game as we've
traditionally known as well as you know
Commissioner Manfred I always positive
three and a potential rule change I
don't just talk about it I'm beyond
being about I want to leave you in a
better place I'd appreciate that
sport as a whole right I hate the shift
with a passion I hate the shift that if
you had a third baseman in a second
baseman had to have at least one foot on
their side of the base as it's
traditionally known and the first and
second baseman at least one foot on
their side of second bases is
traditionally known
I think we're opening things up now
managers I think would go absolutely
nuts over that sort of thing and I know
that Ted Williams used to be shifted
against I get it but this is a different
the the way I look at it is in the world
of football when Mel Blount came in and
they had to change the rules to make
sure that you had to give the wide
receivers at least five yards before you
could contact him it opened up on
offense it opened things up I I'm just
I'm feeling like this is the same exact
thing with baseball okay so let's try to
put this in the kind of framework where
I think about it first of all there's no
doubt I mean I know they shifted against
Ted Williams but if you look at the
number we have increased geometrically
year after year the number of shifts
that are out there right so that is a
change in the game that's not baseball
the club's anybody trying to change the
game it is organically you know the
organizations the clubs are looking at
this and saying I think I can win one
more game by doing it right yes right
and so I do think that the idea of kind
of putting players back to the
positioning that they used to have I
don't think that would be a bad rule
change for us to talk about I actually
think it'd be a good one
now I will tell you even among the
club's there's a difference of opinion
about that some people don't think it
would actually change the way the game
is played by trying to force people back
into position but I do think it's an
example of what I was the broader
phenomenon that I was talking about
before the game changing and raising the
question of whether we oughta regular I
think because again I understand the
concept that just hit the ball whether
ain't that's that's as ancient as they
is
as a phrase you can get baseball right
but I'm not I'm not showing to the park
to watch Bryce Harper maybe bumped up
the left-field line or try and go the
other way and I'm also not paying to see
people trying to swing from their heels
to try and hit it over that's where more
strikeouts comes at least this is my
theory you would obviously know the
metrics in the I always I think your
analysis is right I mean I think so
here's how the debate kind of evolved
historically internally yeah
people started shifting more right and
everybody said you know these are the
greatest athletes in the world don't
worry about it the players will adjust
and we'll get past this phenomenon right
okay and everyone was speculating that
the adjustment would be go the other way
where somebody is not they were right
about two-thirds of it they are the
greatest athletes in the world right
they will adjust unfortunately the way
they adjusted was not going the other
way it was as you point out going up
over the top and that has spurred
additional changes in the game that is
you know led to more of the as people
call them true outcomes so then the last
question for you Commissioner Manfred is
how does this get thrown out is this
part of a collective bargaining
agreement yeah you know look I have you
know we have certain rights to act
unilaterally on rule changes that's kind
of normal in a labor environment right
fundamental issues about what your
product is you should have the right to
act unilaterally I've been reluctant to
do that I have you know multiple winters
in a row gone to the players and tried
to reach negotiated agreements as to
what the change should look like I've
done that because I have respect what
the players think um they control what
goes on on the field and frankly I've
done an out of a larger concern for our
labor relations well I always appreciate
you coming in here thanks it's great it
is great chatting with you I love our
chats and um so your next stop is Fenway
you're going yeah be there about the
Rings I will and I'm excited about ring
ceremonies are a great baseball
tradition you know you see even the most
grizzled that
in player turned into a little kid when
he gets his World Series ring and it's a
great thing well what's also shifted is
the number of of jewels that are on
these things now they are nice just get
me bigger and bigger they are nice
bigger and they're always up in New
England to just it's a fur it's crazy
all right stop but I don't know I
figured that bone at the end of our
conversation good to see you committee
to see Rob Manfred Commissioner baseball
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience